So when I start my concert, I like to face
my back towards the audience to build anticipation.
So that way they think,
"Oh no, who's coming on stage?"
It's me.
[singing]
Oh my God, I'm so excited!
Thanks. I would be too.
So whatever negative energy you have within you,
you gotta let it out.
You can't let anything stand in your way.
'Cause when you sing, it's all about aggression and anger and passion and love and hate.
Let's say Britney or Pink or Lady Caca comes at me, I'm not gonna say,
[singing] "Come at me, bro."
I'm gonna say,
[singing] "Come at me BRO!"
Right?
F*** those f***ing bitch f***s!
It's really hard for me to describe these techniques to regular people.
[singing]
That was good!
Great! I can see where it will go.
[singing well]
That was okay.
I'm not threatened by other singers.
I'm not.
[singing]
Maybe it's only something I can do. Like this:
Oh, okay. I get it.
[singing]
Stop. Stop stop.
Come here for a sec.
Oh, honey! Are you okay?
Maybe you should let your voice rest for a
bit.
Who's next?
I said, who's NEXT?
I'm Christina Aguilera, and this is my singing class.